hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my spider-man cue a whole bunch of
questions about how he fits into the
Avengers are we going to see defenders
so I tried to include as much stuff as
possible there's gonna be a whole bunch
more spider-man and Guardian stuff
happening during the break so make sure
you click that Bell to enable alerts so
that you don't miss out on anything so
here we go joven asks what's your
thoughts on the spider-man logo being
red and yellow connection to Iron Man
hint iron spider anything differ from
his comic book branding no I think
there's gonna be just a little bit of
winking at the iron spider but the suit
that you see him in for most of that the
civil war suit will probably be the only
suit that he wears the one exception to
that is the hoodie that he wears in part
of the trailer the film will probably
jump around in time so we'll probably
see him before Civil War where he's
wearing the goggles in the hoodie then
after Civil War when iron man's like
yeah you can totally keep the suit but
it does not mean that you are an Avenger
so the red on yellow is just a little
bit of eye winking about Marvel in
spider-man coming together in the
presence of Iron Man in the film so it
gets a little meta but I don't think
that he's going to be wearing the actual
iron spider suit that most people think
of when they think I inspire next
question alt FS was that Kraven please
help me
so no there's no Kraven in this movie
but I do think that they'll use him in
the trilogy at some point the person
you're thinking of is the vulture it's
Michael Keaton wearing his jacket with
the fur around the collar like that's
his vulture jacket so that's why he
looks a little bit like Kraven just
because he has that big collar next one
smooth says kingpin is rumored to be in
this movie so I don't think there's
gonna be any kingpin in the actual movie
but Vincent D'Onofrio did say he would
love to be in spider-man the funny thing
about that is that everybody wants to be
in the Spider Man felt like you can see
clark gregg sitting off in the distance
waving his hand please put me in a
spider-man movie this would be so much
fun
so what I think is gonna happen is is if
they ever work kingpin into a spider-man
movie it'll just be at Easter Egg level
you'll hear about the kingpin of crime--
but he'll stay relatively local to
Manhattan you won't hear about him so
much out in Queens where spider-man
spends most of his time
next question Robert asks do you think
they'll do spider-verse with the other
live-action spider-man like Andrew
Garfield Tobey Maguire no I don't think
those are going to do that but as for
other spider people silk is in the movie
the character who turns
the silk in the comics is in but they
might not necessarily do that the thing
about spider-man is that he's one of the
most popular comic book characters of
all time that means that there are a ton
of characters in the spider verse so
there's no way they'll have time to get
to them all in the movies but with
characters like Ned Leeds they might not
do Hobgoblin with characters like silk
they might not actually have her put the
costume on but they totally exist in
that universe it's just the problem is
is the more characters you stuff in the
less time you have to spend developing
other characters so I'm not expecting
Miles Morales or spider-gwen or silk or
even venom to put costumes on in any of
the movies but like we could totally see
Eddie Brock show up next question chef
cat asks what do you think vultures
motivation for being a villain is well
there are a couple things that happen to
him in the comics that they could
include in the movie there was a
business partner that stole all his
money so he had to turn to crime but he
also later in the comics had a grandson
with a medical condition so he was
forced to steal to get the money for his
medical treatments so they could go any
number of different directions but the
way Michael Keaton comes off in the
trailer he seems vicious so maybe he had
a family member that died he has a
daughter in the comics so maybe his
daughter died because of something the
Avengers did that seems like the thing
that they've been going with since civil
war like the Avengers cause collateral
damage and everybody hates them now
next question though Phoenix asks is
there any actor playing Norman Osborn
not as far as we know it seems like
they're holding off on the Osborn stuff
the stuff that you've seen a whole bunch
of in the other movies just because they
might not be in this first movie though
it doesn't mean that they won't ever do
Green Goblin stuff I think that they're
just taking their time so maybe by the
third movie they'll loop them back in
because that'll be almost six years down
the road
they've already dated the second
spider-man movie for fourth of July
weekend 2019 so if production stays on
track you know within about four years
we could see more Green Goblin I think
one of the big criticisms has been them
just redoing the same story in
spider-man movies the origin story over
and over over reliance on the same types
of characters so they're trying to do
something completely different with this
first movie but that doesn't mean
they're never gonna do those other
characters again like Mary Jane or Gwen
Stacy next question kind of a follow-up
to that too
Kota asks can you discuss the
possibility of Gwen or MJ in the sequels
would you like to see play those roles
well there is a rumor that Mary Jane is
in the movie but in a very backdoor
secretive kind of way the thing about
those characters is that they're so
fundamental to the spider-man character
that you kind of have to do them like
you could get away with not doing Green
Goblin there are so many spider-man
villains that you could make the main
villain of a movie but there are really
only a handful of characters that are
very close to the Peter Parker character
and because he's in high school he hangs
out with his friends all the time so he
would run into those people pretty
quickly so I will say I do think that
Mary Jane is somewhere in spider-man
homecoming but we won't learn about it
to like the very end of the film and
it'll be something really off handed
like oh my god she's been here this
whole time and we didn't realize it but
if you're worried about them not being
anywhere in there don't worry they're
just not gonna include them in any of
the marketing for the movie
next question Gaming speedster asks what
other upgrades do you think spider-man
got so I think it's just you know
utility belt like little things that
make him seem more like comic-book
spider-man the suit is extra durable it
holds more gear more webbing cartridges
it probably helps him with a couple cool
trick shots with his webbing like look
at this big scene here where he's trying
to hold this boat together this is crazy
so the materials that Stark used to
build the suit are much more advanced
than the stuff that he was using for his
homemade suit so like his webbing is
probably just as strong as the webbing
that he originally made but his homemade
gauntlets would probably get crushed
under the stress of all this weight so
the stark tech suit is just a much
stronger version of the comic book
costume and you can also kind of see his
eyes open and dilate like the eyes move
a little bit like Deadpool's eyes moved
in that movie with CG but because it's
stark tech they're more like camera
irises I think a really good example is
when he's fighting the fake Avengers you
see his eyes move
guys wait a minute you want the real
Avengers like he doesn't need to tell
the suit to open the irises they just
automatically respond to his muscle
contractions so the easiest explanation
is just expect the eyes to work a lot
like Deadpool's eyes during that movie
next question Zen master asks and wonder
what Tony means by other people is he
talking about shield Street heroes like
the defenders does he mean Captain
America Secret Avengers really he's just
talking about the adults like the adults
we'll handle this you go to school and
be a kid if you really want to dig into
that yeah I mean shield does exist it's
above board now so technically they'd be
the ones to respond to that but if
anyone he's talking about the actual
Avengers like he says Peter isn't a real
Avenger yet don't worry the adults the
Avengers will handle stuff like that you
go on and be a kid have fun go to school
he seems to have a great interest in
Peter just continuing to be a kid so
that's like the worst possible advice
you could give to teenage Peter Parker
of course he wants to prove himself and
be a hero so there's no way he's gonna
listen to Iron Man next question Spencer
asks I'm seeing a fair amount of Iron
Man in the trailer but when Iron Man is
flying next to him I'm wondering how
large a part he's going to play I still
want this to be a spider-man movie so
that's totally true
it is a Spider Man movie Iron Man is
just gonna be in part of it but you can
see how they want to height the movie up
as much as possible so they're gonna put
as much Iron Man as they possibly can
into those trailers so I will be willing
to bet that the scenes that we saw with
the exception of like a big final battle
where Ironman helps out that's pretty
much every scene Iron Man is in in the
movie like when he drops him off when he
gives him the talking to at the Avengers
base look kid let the adults handle this
and then when he's flying through the
neighborhood with them you know maybe
like a little bit more but if this is
gonna be like a two two and a half hour
movie I'd be willing to bet that there's
as little as like 20 minutes of Iron Man
in the movie which is about how much
Spiderman was in civil wars
there's probably as much Iron Man in the
spider-man movie as Spiderman was in
Civil War next question Israel asks do
you think that we'll see any connections
to the defenders show or any of the
Netflix series you know maybe
confusing him for daredevil because they
both wear red suits but that's about it
like Easter Egg level they've been
really tight-lipped about what's going
on with the defenders as a Avengers
infinity war so I don't think they want
a shoehorn in any defenders if we're not
actually gonna see them moving around
and they'll be relatively localized to
Manhattan like you have Iron Fist
happening in Manhattan proper you have
Hell's Kitchen you have Harlem there's
very little going on in Queens and
that's primarily where most of
spider-man is gonna take place
so best-case scenario somebody confuses
him for daredevil the guy in the red
suit like you hear people talk about a
man in a red suit saving people and in
spider-man's like no that's not me
that's that's another guy so I know I
already talked about kingpin though that
would actually be a really badass
crossover just because he's such a big
spider-man character in the comics but
thank you so much everyone for dropping
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do I'm not expecting another trailer
at least until the Superbowl but they'll
probably drop some teasers before then
there will be spider-man giveaways
happening every week like I'll just keep
doing it don't worry there'll be plenty
of bonus videos so I will say
congratulations to the first winner a
male guy can you in a comiXology gift
card please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details so what's gonna happen
tomorrow is the Walking Dead finale is
happening so I'll do video for that
there'll be some Game of Thrones and
then there'll be more comic book stuff
happening on Monday while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to
re-watch those spider-man trailers again
and you can click here for the trailer
for the next episode of the flash thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you